more meetings between amazon and mgm
about a stargate reboot but it may not
be good news for brad wright's project
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
uh first of all i'm going to apologize
about doing this very quick and dirty
video because of family commitments i
don't have time to do a proper video
today but
i'm getting news from my sources that
working around mgm and amazon this is
coming from two different sources that
actually in the last week maybe 10 days
nothing since certain when these
happened there were meetings between
amazon and mgm executives i will do a
follow-up more detailed video as soon as
i can but i really wanted to get this
information out there as quickly as i
could
now according to my source at this
meeting there was not just executives in
charge of
written script products and there was a
marketing people and legal
representation from amazon
now my source is telling me that he
believes and now this part is a rumor i
know the meetings happened um we're not
100 certain when because i'm getting two
different dates there's a reason why i'm
being a little bit vague one source has
told me that these happened on tuesday
just gone the other source believes they
happened um the friday before that
um
maybe there were two meetings and that's
where the confusion has come from i
can't i can't be certain
um but basically what they're saying is
and this is the opinion and this is the
rumor of one of the sources who is um
his actual background is more to do with
the legal and contractual side of things
and he is saying that he believes the
only reason have marketing and legal
people in that meeting
is if they are looking up at contracts
so he believes that they are looking at
either
this is an early stage preparation for
green lighting but that is
way out there is you know that is
speculation on a high level but he says
that is one reason why to have these two
people in the room
or there is some big change going ahead
or they're trying to
understand some legal element
his opinion and this is this person's
opinion
is that um they're actually looking at
maybe going a completely different way
with the stargate project and not
actually going with brad wright's
project now he has said to me this
particular source repeatedly that amazon
have never been that excited about brad
wright's version and is the script that
we have out there that they've always
preferred something a bit bigger they
wanted a much um grander project and
they weren't massively excited by what
brad wright had produced for the initial
script
so he is telling me that they are
looking at the legal side of things
because they're wondering whether they
can remove brad wright from the future
project of stargate and they're just
looking at the contracts and things to
make sure
that anything that they then decided to
do isn't going to cause contractual
problems
he then went on to tell me that he
believes the marketing people are there
to
try to understand what any fallout would
be if they did decide to remove brad
right from the project now that is i'm
going to repeat rumor and speculation
and opinion of the source this is a
source that has spoken to me about
stargate lots a lot of times has been
right a lot um
but it is his opinion he wasn't in the
meeting so it is speculation um
but because of where the information has
come from i think it's worth um sharing
it with you guys um
it's interesting that meeting's still
going on it's not surprising that
meetings are going on um i would say
that this is a multi-million dollar
project when stargate starts you know
and they were talking about six to nine
million dollars an episode for um the
new series which is bang on sort of on
average what these shows sort of cost
nowadays i mean enterprise and star
strange new world sorry costs 11 to 12
million an episode um so
it would be an expensive project they're
talking about 10 to 12 episodes so
you're talking about 100 million dollar
project when stargate starts a long line
of most big sci-fi budget series it cost
this sort of money so of course they're
going to be talking about these things a
lot and when they start building up
towards some sort of release of some
sort of um official green lighting we're
going to have lots of meetings with
marketing and legal people in the room
um as well as other creative types
whatever this isn't just going to be a
creative decision
but it's exciting news i'm really
interested to find out where this is
going to go on i should get more details
over the next few days um and as soon as
i get that information i will share it
with you guys as i always do
you may notice i'm wearing my hashtag we
want stargate t-shirt you can go to sign
dashtrack.com and buy yours we're going
to be doing the twitter run on the 27th
of july we're going to demand the amazon
make our favorite tv show and get it
back in our screens as quickly as
possible we're going to put a collective
boot
up amazon's backside and through twitter
through facebook through any other way
we can and just by liking and
subscribing to this video you know
you're going to be showing your support
as well
so you can go to sidetrack.com you can
also get t-shirts with your favorite sg
team on there sg1 sg usga
pick your team
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
share the video or wherever the hell you
like and if you want to really support
the channel and you like my content
consider hitting the join button and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker as
i say i will get a more detailed full
video out as soon as i get the full
information and i want to get sources
from a couple of more different places
people that i know should know about
this i'm still waiting to hear back from
but i just wanted to get this
information out to you as quickly as i
could alright guys thanks very much see
you next time
[Music]
you